R if you want to come on stage tonight
you want to look the GOP voters in the
eye and tell them you resign I will turn
over my yield my time to you all right
joining me now R McDaniel chairwoman of
the Republican National Committee R
thanks so much for being with us um VI
and others are saying that under your
leadership Republicans have lost
election after election and positing the
question you know why should you retain
your job given the track record of the
party under your leadership and to that
what do you say well first I'm going to
continue to focus on Joe Biden and
Democrats and I think there was a moment
missed La during that debate by vake to
talk about the fact that we still have
13 American host hostages in Israel the
fact that for the first time ever in the
history of either party we had a Jewish
co-sponsor for a debate and we are in
very perilous times in our country and I
do think Republican voters and I hear
this echoed all all the time are tired
of the circular firing squad within our
party and they're saying can we please
talk about Joe Biden and the Democrats
and the border and Fentanyl and crime
and what's happening to our kids and
inflation but I'll definitely defend my
record as chair listen R I think I think
I I agree with you let me just say I I
mean all that all that you just said I I
couldn't agree with more but and and
you're right I mean obviously that that
that should be a key Focus but I I know
you believe in accountability you talk
about it all the time I mean everyone I
mean I'm accountable you're some account
that's what I asked you when you went
into another you know another I was
going to go there sorry I took too long
on the answer but I was getting there
I'm not trying to avoid anything let me
promise you that Laura listen when when
V didn't vote in 2016 I was leading
Michigan to the first win in history in
30 years in 2018 we defied the odds we
got three Senators people like Josh
Holly that allowed president Trump to
build the largest conserv ative majority
on the Supreme Court in 2022 the RNC
which is a turnout machine right we're
not The Messengers we don't create the
messages for the campaigns those are the
Consultants who get very very well paid
one of the things though that happened
was I think in Virginia people were
wondering where the money was whether
they were going to get some help from
the RNC and I I know at one point you
said that that you were not asked for
money in Virginia but a source a
republican Source familiar with the
youngin team in Virginia told the angle
tonight that that is false and there
meaning your story keeps changing anyone
who thinks Virginia Republicans wouldn't
want help when we knew we'd be outs
spent isn't being serious you know R
they were out spent by8 million Glenn
yunan and did a phenomenal job and he
raised a lot of money a lot of people
don't understand fundraising I can't
raise State dollars I don't get
unlimited convention and and State
dollars uh and these were state house
and state senate races the RNC is a
federal committee so I mean come on can
you just this these are people who come
after me all the time they're on Twitter
they're all the time and let's see their
results what did they do in Virginia how
much money did they give but let me
stand by something else in 2022 we took
back the house and the RNC is part of
that we're building the road and we're
launching Bank your vote we've got to do
that we got roll but thank you for
joining us tonight we have a lot more to
get to next hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else